poetry can make someone fall in love
with you poetry can make you fall in
love with yourself
i come to poetry because of the
questions what are we doing here why who
would make a place like this and there's
no one answer it's to investigate
poetry became my activism
my own way of processing and dealing
with the native rights movements
it goes where words cannot go speaks
what words cannot speak and so then the
question is where do i start
i'm offering you different kinds of
approaches to poetry or to your innate
creativity in this class we'll be
talking about imagery writing rhythm
revision and it's good for anyone you
don't have to be a poet everyone's paths
are different
a line has to have a purpose otherwise
it's like a two by four going to the
middle of the room for no reason
what do you do if you get blocked go
outside the predictability take your
failed love poem and put it in the shape
of a recipe
while i'm still waking up halfway in the
dream space i just start writing for a
half hour without thinking poems come
through that were beyond the thinking
mind it will take you to other levels of
perception poetry that opened doors
poetry can open eyes it can take our
grief and turn it to the depths the
muscle the toughness you need to be able
to climb
i am joy harjo and this is masterclass
[Music]
you